ready to play a game
i'm ready called country star confession
this is topo chico it's not a beer
i promise last time you cried watching
tv or a movie
last night this is us well thank you for
sharing it with me
[Music]
takes you down every single time
every time who is the most famous person
on your phone and was the last thing you
texted them ashton kutcher
oh we've been buddies for a while now i
can't remember what we talked about
sometimes he just randomly texts
and i'll randomly text him we don't
really ever talk about anything
world changing but he's he's been a he's
been a really good friend of mine
what is your biggest fear my biggest
fear i mean as cliche as spiders i
hate them like with a with a big passion
ultimate cheat meal uh shake shack
yes me too every time i got the u.s if
that was remotely healthy i would eat it
five days a week
do you dip your fries into the shake
absolutely
is there any other way there's no other
way uh
your go-to karaoke song gosh
um my heart will go on by celine dion
[Music]
that's a good one it's hard one for like
10 years
yeah i mean i sing it like six octaves
down
but it's still my go-to what is your
wife's nickname for you
uh honey or tr
it's a lot easier than saying tom strett
so i love it